(gentle melodic music)
- [David] When we first moved here,
people thought we were crazy.
- [Lise] There's a reason why
there's not a lot of
farms here in Minnesota;
it's not much soil; the climate is harsh.
- [David] We knew the land could produce;
we figured we'd figure it out.
(melodic orchestral music)
- [Narrator] This Great Big Story
was made possible by Horizon Organic.
- I'm Lise Abazs. This is
my husband, David Abazs,
and we are off grid organic
farmers in Finland, Minnesota.
- [David] Finland is a small community
along the North Shore of Lake Superior.
We've been farming this land
for the last 30 plus years.
People had said you can't farm in Finland;
the soil was both
infertile and challenging.
You can't get a shovel into the ground
'cause it's full of rocks.
- But it didn't matter;
everything, it just felt right.
The soil, industrial farming
treats it as a medium to grow crops;
you insert the nutrients,
and the crop growers,
but organic farming focuses
on making that soil its
own living organism.
You have healthy soil, you
end up with healthy plants;
and so we focused on making sure
we were feeding the soil,
not just the plants.
- [David] This is all good soil;
it starts to get a little denser here.
Through time, through compost,
through cover crops and care,
we're able to see results,
and now the fertility
is so much greater than it's ever been.
(melodic orchestral music)
- [Lise] Our growing season
can be as short as 33 days.
In the spring we grow lots
of greens, we have lettuce,
spinach, kale, we have radishes and beets.
- We need water, we need
food, we need energy;
we have tried to figure out
how do we do all of those.
Everything we run is from
solar and wind power.
Our water is pumped from the Earth;
we use a compost toilet.
- [Lise] And of course, you know,
what homestead would be complete
without a flock of free range chickens?
Most of what we grow is
distributed to customers
through a CSA, which is
Community Supported Agriculture.
It's a way for small farmers
to get dependable sales of their products.
We sell about 50 shares,
which can feed a couple of 100 people.
- [David] For many years
we've been involved
in the social fabric in the community,
so we installed solar at the fire station
and then the community center,
so that that was all part
of kind of mainstreaming
renewable energy into our community.
- [Lise] Sharing what we've
learned by living this way
will hopefully make the world better.
(light melodic music)